the movie begins in a world where the
melting of polar ice has resulted in all
continents becoming submerged in water
forcing humans to adapt to their new
environment they now live in rugged
floating communities known as atolls
feeding on seafood and living off of
trades plants dirt and soil cost more
than gold and people use their urine for
cultivation due to lack of fresh water
in other words this movie was the
inspiration for burning man although the
world is turned into an endless giant
ocean many believe there still exists
dry land somewhere several groups of
people are looking for the said magical
place in hopes of living a better life
but no one has been successful yet we
are introduced to a man named mariner
who lives in a ramshackle boat that
appears to be made of scrap boy costner
sure loved showing off his ass in the
90s he is seen urinating in a small
vessel and then pouring this urine into
a machine that converts it into
drinkable water in the boat he has
planted a lime tree a rare commodity in
the world with no land mariner does
fishing and collects reusable trash from
the ocean for his survival one afternoon
after a dive he notices another boat
approaching him the man on the other
boat tells mariner about an atoll where
he obtained various supplies he wants to
trade them but when mariner learns that
the man wants nothing in return he
begins to doubt him he soon realizes
that the man has stolen all of his lives
simultaneously a group of smokers
arrives in their jet skis and begins
attacking them despite the fact that
mariner's boat is made up of scrap it is
fast and he is able to escape whereas
the other man is apprehended by the
smokers following this mariner arrives
at the atoll a floating city surrounded
by high metal walls at the gate he says
he's there to trade his belongings upon
heading inside he reveals that he has
some genuine dirt to trade which is
extremely rare seeing this the people of
the atoll give him 124 chits in exchange
for a jar of dirt he then uses the same
chits to purchase a tomato plant which
is full of dirt and some other scraps
from a woman named helen after the trade
he is returning to his boat when a
family approaches him and asks him to
impregnate their daughter but he refuses
to do so not accepting a woman makes
them think he's nuts so they order the
locals to stop him after he is
apprehended the locals discover mariner
is a mutant with gills behind his ears
and webbed feet mariner tries to fight
back but he is captured under a fishing
net later that night helen meets with an
elderly man named gregor and inquires as
to when they can depart for dry land
gregor informs that the direction for
the dry land is tattooed on the back of
a little girl named enola but he does
not understand it gregor then considers
asking mariner about it who is
imprisoned inside a cage following this
he approaches mariner and inquires about
the mutation but mariner appears to be
dismissive of him only when gregor shows
the picture of the tattoo does mariners
seem interested in exchange for the
information mariner wants him to open
the cage but gregor is not allowed to do
so the next day the local people decide
to drown mariner in the swamp pit by
lowering his cage but to his good
fortune simultaneously an army of
smokers led by deacon arrives to attack
the atoll they are also looking for the
mythical dry land and want to get to the
little girl who holds the secret to its
path soon after the smokers encircle the
atoll and begin shooting with large
machine guns killing several atoll
residents eventually the smokers with
the jet skis enter the building via
self-built ramps inside gregor fills a
balloon and inadvertently flies away
abandoning helen and enola meanwhile
mariner tries to break free but his cage
collapses causing it to shrink gradually
helen notices this and rushes to his aid
she agrees to assist him but only if he
takes her and dinola with him to which
he agrees following this he tells the
girls to open the gate until he starts
his boat unfortunately the gate becomes
stuck so mariner uses the ship's rigging
to fly up open the gate and jump back to
the boat enola and helen also board the
boat and make their way out of atoll on
the other hand the smoker with machine
guns continues to fire in an
undetermined direction causing their
leader deacon's boat to explode however
deacon dives into the sea at that
precise moment saving his life after the
battle the smokers continue looking for
enola having found that she has the
tattoo of the way to dry land the
smokers bind one of the locals and
inquire about enola fearful of death the
man reveals everything he knows but he
is killed anyway as they sail away helen
asks mariner if he knows how to get to
dry land to which he responds in the
affirmative however he advises her to
throw enola away before going there
because they have limited food and water
helen tries to persuade him not to do so
she even offers herself in turn for the
little girl's life but mariner dismisses
her men with gills and webbed feet are
asexual after a while mariner notices
enola drawing on his boat which
irritates him and he throws her into the
water helen panics knowing that enola is
unable to swim so she dives in to save
her mariner appears to abandon the two
in the water but he later returns to
pick them up as soon as they get on the
boat the smokers arrive on a plane and
begin shooting at them while mariner
goes down to retrieve his weapon helen
rushes towards the large spear gun and
fires at it without mariner's permission
as a result the plane is now tethered to
the boat by the metal robe and begins
circling it tangling it in a web when
mariner notices this he rushes up to cut
the rope and untangle the boat while the
smokers do the same a few moments later
the smokers are able to shoot the rope
and fly away whereas mariner swings off
and lands in the water he is furious at
helen for destroying the boat so he cuts
both her and inola's hair as punishment
weird on the other hand deacon guesses
their location and deploys his men to
find enola while sailing they come
across a drifter who admits to having
some important papers and offers to
trade them in exchange for helen helen
refuses but mariner agrees the drifter
takes helen to his boat while mariner
quickly examines the paper and discovers
that it is useless he quickly rushes
into the drifter's boat and cancels the
deal this enrages the drifter the
drifter says he has a zero return policy
and tries to stab mariner a fight ensues
and mariner kills the drifter in the
next scene mariner demonstrates how he
fishes he dives into the water as bait
and soon a massive mutated fish appears
he then uses his weapon to kill the fish
and prepares food for everyone mariner
was rude to them at first but now he
appears to be nice to them as he starts
talking to enola he allows enola to draw
with a colored pencil and also teaches
her how to swim helen appears concerned
as she witnesses their bond growing
stronger after a while they come across
the barter outpost and notice some men
waving at them mariner is suspicious so
he looks beneath the water and discovers
the smokers waiting for them he
immediately turns the boat around in
order to flee but the smokers give chase
they somehow manage to avoid the attacks
of the smokers mariner then deploys the
extra sails as parachutes allowing them
to flee faster after they are safe
mariner forces helen to reveal the truth
about enola's tattoo so she discloses
that the tattoo is the path to dry land
when mariner hears this he claims that
dry land is a myth but she does not
believe him as a result he decides to
show her he places helen inside a large
bubble and submerges her he can breathe
through his gills so he takes her deep
into the ocean and shows her the past
world which is completely covered in
water which shocks her meanwhile enola
is waiting for them in the boat when she
notices something in the water and
quickly hides when mariner and helen
swim to the surface they discover that
they have been apprehended by the
smokers deacon coerces them into telling
him about enola but they both remain
silent deacon then shoots at the air
pretending to kill them and as a result
enola comes out being concerned and she
is quickly captured by the smokers
deacon orders his men to kill mariner
and talon but the two escape by diving
into the water helen says she can't hold
her breath that long and mariner tells
her that he'll breathe for her how's he
gonna do that oh he'll just make out
with her for a while i see after some
time they return to the surface and to
discover that their boat has been
destroyed on the other hand deacon
pretends to be nice to enola and
inquires about the tattoo behind her
back but she remains silent he then
offers her some colored pencils and asks
her again but she doesn't say anything
back on the destroyed boat mariner and
helen are hopeless helen inquires as to
why he did not accept her when she
offered herself to which he responds
that she did not like him then the
answer touches her heart and she kisses
him before the two of them make love on
the boat because there's no turn on like
knowing that your surrogate daughter has
been kidnapped the following day mariner
attempts to repair the boat but they
discover gregor in his hot air balloon
this guy's nuts gregor then takes him to
the boat where the survivors of atoll
are staying at night they talk about
going on a search for dry land but the
people aren't ready to look for enola
because it's dangerous to face the
smokers mariner then decides to go on
his own in search of the little girl
after a while he arrives at the smoker's
ship and enters it killing the smokers
one after another i can imagine no
scarier death than being held under
water by kevin costner
meanwhile deacon gathers the smokers and
lies to them claiming to have discovered
the way to dry land he orders everyone
to begin rowing thereby propelling the
ship forward as the men begin to row
mariner approaches deacon alone and asks
to free enola when deacon refuses
mariner threatens to drop the flame into
the oil reserve which will cause the
entire ship to explode deacon does not
believe he will act irrationally but
mariner is batshit and drops the flame
causing a massive explosion deacon then
flees with the little girl before
mariner reaches the top at the podium
and notices him on the plane he
immediately fires a spear gun at the
ship's fence and zip lines down
following that he uses the metal rope to
create a barrier causing the plane to
crash before taking off fortunately
enola is unharmed and the two of them
embrace however the ship begins to break
down leaving them with no means of
escape fortunately helen gregor and an
atoll resident arrive before the ship
breaks down they drop the rope and pull
mariner and denola up but deacon grabs
the rope and climbs up as well when
helen notices this she throws a heavy
object at him and denola kicks him
causing him to fall into the ocean
mariner and helen make it to the hot air
balloon but a persistent deacon jumps on
a jet ski and shoots at the hot air
balloon causing enola to fall into the
water deacon orders his men to capture
the little girl but mariner is quick to
respond he grabs the rope and ties it
around his leg before leaping from the
hot air balloon he successfully grabs
anola the rope becomes a bungee cord and
he springs up just in time causing the
jet skis to collide and explode finally
they reach the hot air balloons safely
this time gregor is able to understand
enola's tattoo and head in the direction
of dry land after several days of flight
they spot a bird on their hot air
balloon when they look further they are
astounded to see land for the first time
in their lives they are overjoyed to
finally be here and begin exploring the
area a few moments later they notice a
small hut and enter it to find a
couple's bones lying together they also
discover the map drawing which is
similar to the one on enola's back that
hut is revealed to be owned by enola's
family her family appears to have sent
her away in the hope that she will bring
more people to dry land meanwhile
mariner finds the land to be
uncomfortable plus look at that leather
jerkin and those earrings this guy can't
be held down by one lady and he feels
that he belongs in the sea he then
approaches enola and informs her that he
is leaving which saddens her he tells
her that he isn't born for dry land but
she tries to assure him that he will
adapt however he doesn't change his mind
and bidzinola and helen won final
goodbye before departing in the final
scene helen andy nola realized that
they're on the summit of mount everest
crazy they then watch mariners sailing
away from the cliff subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching